we live on the continent of elios
four realms surrounding a holy land at
its center
[Music]
a thousand years ago our lands endured a
vicious war with the fel dragon
we called upon heroes from other worlds
to aid us heroes known as emblems
with them the warriors of our nations
fought as one
in the end we were victorious in
defeating and imprisoning the fel dragon
in the years since our world has been
safe
but now
i sense a resurrection
the binding weakens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're awake oh you're really awake yeah
a thousand years that's how long i've
been asleep
what are those horrible things
if i may
you are a divine dragon
a member of a royal family of dragons
revered as deities the war
the fel dragon
i feel like i can almost remember
but
[Music]
[Music]
leave it to me
it is rather quiet i know
but it will liven up as we gain allies
[Music]
the time has come
now as one emblem
[Music]
please grant me your strength
[Music]
she asked me to gather all of the rings
and bring peace back to elios
[Music]
hello everyone
i'm yoshiaki koizumi and i'll be your
guide for today's nintendo
direct what you just saw was the latest
installment of the fire emblem series
fire emblem engage
in addition to the standard version
we'll also be releasing the fire emblem
engage divine edition containing
collectible items
please look forward to more information
about this game in the future
[Music]
let's take a look at our first batch of
headlines
it takes two to tango
cody and may's relationship is on the
rocks
but it gets even tougher
when they're turned into dolls
to get their bodies back they'll brave
an onslaught of challenges where working
together is the only way forward
team up and cooperate with a friend in
this critically acclaimed two-player
platforming adventure
even the bumpiest road can be travel
with someone by your side
venture through fantastical worlds
filled with challenging experiences
around every corner
in addition to single system play the
game can also be played on two systems
via local wireless or online with a pal
via the free friends pass
help cody and may return to normal
with a partner of course
it takes two launches on the nintendo
switch system november 4th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
[Music]
the forbidden story begins
[Music]
after mysteriously vanishing as a child
ruka minozuki visits an abandoned
hospital in search of her lost memories
use the camera obscura to repel evil
spirits and uncover the memories that
were sealed away a dark curse looms near
what ancient rituals will be revealed
fatal frame mask of the lunar eclipse
launches for the first time in the west
on nintendo switch next year
[Music]
there's a new hero who looks mechanical
introducing wave 2 of the xenoblade
chronicles 3 expansion pass for the
xenoblade chronicles 3 game
this is eno a new hero she appears to be
a mechanical
[Music]
complete her quest to have her join your
party
expanding your options for classes and
battle strategies
challenge battles will also be added
test your medal in consecutive battles
against top enemies
defeat all enemy waves to earn rewards
challenge even stronger enemies to earn
valuable accessories and special outfits
[Music]
more hero and gameplay additions will
arrive in wave three
wave two of the xenoblade chronicles 3
expansion pass launches on nintendo
switch october 13th
[Music]
get drawn into these nintendo switch
games
nautical nonsense begins when spongebob
and patrick make a wish that unravels
the very fabric of the universe in this
3d platforming adventure you'll travel
through portals to seven outlandish wish
worlds like prehistoric kelp forest and
wild west jellyfish fields explore using
all sorts of wacky moves don over 30
fantastic cosmic costumes and meet your
favorite bikini bottom residents from
the tv series voiced by their original
actors that's it soak up spongebob
squarepants the cosmic shake launching
on nintendo switch next year
you're already
fit
box with familiar characters from fist
of the north star they'll be your
instructors in exercise mode leading you
through various boxing drills defeat as
many enemies as you can with just your
fists in battle mode or take on rivals
in boss battles including jaggi fitness
boxing fist of the north star launches
on nintendo switch march 2023
this ain't your uncle's dodge ball throw
whatever you can at opponents in this
hilariously hard-hitting party game
embrace the absurdity of frantic
minigames each one featuring ridiculous
rules in madcap arenas customize your
character from head to toe with hundreds
of accessories plus challenge up to six
friends and frenemies in local and
online play they won't even know what
hit them oddballers launches on nintendo
switch early next year
a small fox washes ashore on a ruined
island braved the unknown in this
isometric action-adventure game your
only clue here is the manual traverse
the island's interconnected realms to
retrieve its missing pages
dangerous traps and even more dangerous
monsters lurk around every corner
[Music]
what long lost secrets will the island
reveal
tunic launches on the nintendo switch
system september 27th pre-orders begin
today on nintendo eshop
new intel has arrived for these front
mission remakes
full remix of two front mission games
are storming in in front mission 1
remake you'll pilot giant machines
called bonzers in tactical turn-based
combat
as you progress you'll obtain skills
that can help you gain the upper hand
against opponents
you can also test your medal at the
coliseum
[Music]
continue the battle in the sequel
previously unreleased outside of japan
take advantage of additional features
like more terrain effects weapon and
armor attributes and over 80 new skills
added from the first game
front mission 1 remix launches on
nintendo switch this november brunt
mission 2 remake will launch a nintendo
switch next year and in the future a
remake of front mission 3 will also
launch on nintendo switch
[Music]
it's a wonderful life for a new
generation
after nearly 20 years a beloved farming
experience is reborn
[Music]
welcome back to forgotten valley
here you'll manage a farm passed down to
you by your father
restore and expand your farm as you
nurture crops
care for your friendly animals and help
the land flourish
[Music]
befriend the townsfolk while you're out
and about in the valley
[Music]
you might even meet your future partner
and start a family
in this installment those around you
will grow older as time goes on
their appearances will change over the
years
your child will also choose their career
based on how you raise them
[Music]
an especially wonderful farm life and
forgotten valley lies ahead
[Music]
story of seasons a wonderful life
launches on nintendo switch summer 2023
[Music]
[Music]
the first post-launch splatfest for
splatoon 3 has been confirmed
here's the theme
what would you bring to a deserted
island gear grub or fun
[Music]
so many incredible possibilities which
team will you join
and more free updates are planned for
splatoon 3.
[Music]
be on the lookout for more info in the
future
[Music]
so squids
what did you think
what would you bring to a deserted
island
as for me i've already decided i hope
you'll all participate as well
next please take a look at this
[Music]
introducing a brand new game in the
octopath traveler series
eight new travelers embark on a journey
through the land of celestia with that
we could realize a world without
conflict
without bloodshed
i'm going to become a star
and bring smiles to people's faces just
like mama i'm hitting the road i'll be
back once i eliminate that devil called
poverty from the world the man who took
everything from me shall die by my hand
not again not this stench a stench of
blood
doubt is what i do
leave the hunting to me you'll have all
the tasty meat you want i need to
rediscover who i am
explore a wide world set in a bustling
era
each traveler's path action differs
between day and night
our lord knows well the ways of the
world what will happen when their paths
intertwine what's that
and what adventures await them in this
new world
[Music]
the eight travelers each have their own
story to tell
where will their journeys lead them and
you
octopath traveler 2 launches on nintendo
switch february 24 2023
what you just saw was octopath traveler
2 from square enix
[Music]
please look forward to the journeys of
eight new heroes
let's see some more headlines
a magical home is waiting for you
welcome to your new fairy tale life in
faye farm
cultivate your homestead
and forge everlasting friendships in
this farm simulation rpg
[Music]
discover magical spells to grow crops
face off against mischievous foes
and explore the enchanted realms of
azoria
along the way you'll befriend a lively
cast of characters who call this island
their home tend and grow your fairy tale
farmstead solo or together with up to
four players in local or online
multiplayer by gathering resources and
crafting items you'll be able to
customize your home and enjoy this
mesmerizing adventure even more
as the seasons change
new spellbinding surprises can be
unlocked that'll help you restore azoria
to its natural splendor
[Music]
magic awaits in faye farm launching
exclusively on nintendo switch spring
2023
[Music]
it's a musical blast from the past
celebrate the 35th anniversary of the
final fantasy series with the latest
theater rhythm game
[Music]
enjoy iconic songs like one winged angel
torn from the heavens
and more
there are 385 songs total
songs are categorized by game so you can
play each stage while experiencing the
series through the music
[Music]
in addition two players locally can
complete stages in pair style while up
to four players can battle to the beat
in online multi-battle theater rhythm
final bar line begins its symphony on
the nintendo switch system february 16
2023 pre-orders begin today on nintendo
eshop
after the game's launch pay dlc songs
from the saga series
nier series
[Music]
octopath traveler
live alive and more will be released
that's 90 additional songs
plus additions containing a season pass
and 27 extra songs including melodies of
life will be available
[Music]
a cosmic adventure is just around the
corner blast off on an adventure of
galactic proportions with mario and the
rabbids
let's dive into exploration
freely roam through all sorts of
wondrous worlds each one jam-packed with
discoveries
[Music]
find coins
unlock hidden paths
and help out the locals with their
troubles
[Music]
at shops you can get items that'll come
in handy during battles after each quest
or battle your team will earn rewards
and get stronger sparks are here to lend
a helping hand recruit up to 30
different sparks each with their own
special powers and skills they can help
spark a decisive victory
can mario and the rabbits put an end to
the darkness
mario plus rabbits sparks of hope
launches on nintendo switch october 20th
pre-orders are available now on nintendo
eshop
a gold edition can also be pre-ordered
containing the base game weapon skins
and a season pass
[Music]
restore peace between humans and
monsters
roon factory 3 returns on nintendo
switch
[Music]
take a break from quest to chat with the
locals cultivate crops and care for
monsters
among other relaxing activities
you can also transform
into a monster
your abilities in battle and
conversations with the locals will vary
depending on your form
your choices will also cause different
events to occur plus a brand new mode
has been added to help you enjoy more
quality time with your in-game spouse
roon factory 3 special launches on
nintendo switch next year
plus a new roon factory series will
launch in the future
[Music]
more nintendo 64 games are on the way
pilot wings 64.
mario party
mario party 2
mario party 3
pokemon stadium
pokemon stadium 2
1080 snowboarding
excitebike 64.
these games will gradually be added in
the future you can play a selection of
nintendo 64 games and enjoy many more
gaming benefits with an active nintendo
switch online plus expansion pack
membership
oh and there's one more game we should
mention
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
why not mix things up with these
nintendo switch games
live your best life on the newly
discovered continent of antoisia in this
immersive rpg
perform over 100 types of daily tasks to
build character and deepen your
relationships with the locals
in doing so you'll gain access to
different job classes and abilities
a grand adventure into the unknown aways
various daylight launches on nintendo
switch later today
a malfunction causes you to crash land
on a strange planet build a new rocket
from scratch in this management sim game
scour the planet for materials
then build machines to refine them into
various resources
eventually you'll construct multiple
production lines like these
but the planet's creatures will attack
so keep them at bay
factorio launches on nintendo switch
october 28th
a young girl named ib visits an art
museum with her parents in this 2d
exploration adventure
she wanders through a busy gallery by
the artist guertena until
one particular piece draws her in
will she be able to safely return to her
own world
every decision affects her fate in ib
launching on nintendo switch spring 2023
[Music]
mario striker's battle league where
eight players locally on one system can
get gritty is getting a second
pre-update
joining the roster are pauline a
physical powerhouse with fast movements
and strong tackles
and diddy kong a midfield speedster with
dazzling techniques and high pass
accuracy
plus more gear and another stadium are
being added
the second pre-update launches this
month
[Music]
the final summer begins
[Music]
when strange islands suddenly appear
riza and friends set sail to investigate
in order to protect their homeland from
impending danger
sprawling landscapes set the stage for
your adventure
freely explore this vast world and forge
your own path in this charming rpg
11 heroes from all walks of life will
join your party
during battle work with your allies to
activate various skills which can be
swapped out when needed
teamwork is paramount after all
[Music]
new features are also in store
the keys to this lively adventure are in
your hands
[Music]
atelier rise of three alchemist of the
end and the secret key launches on the
nintendo switch system february 24th
2023
[Music]
wave 3 is on the way
here's a sneak peek at two courses
racing into wave three mary mountain
from mario carter
[Music]
peach gardens from mario kart ds
[Applause]
[Music]
wave three of the mario kart 8 deluxe
booster course pass dlc for the mario
kart 8 deluxe game launches this holiday
active nintendo switch online plus
expansion pack members can enjoy this
dlc at no additional cost the dlc can
also be purchased on its own
[Music]
how was that
next we have some news to share about
nintendo switch sports
in the next free update golf will be
added
[Music]
of course you can play these locally
additionally up to eight players online
can play at the same time on the same
course in survival golf
those with the most strokes will be out
we previously announced that the update
would release this fall however we'd
like a bit more time for development so
the update is now planned for this
holiday
please wait just a little longer
next we have a special guest
mr miyamoto
hello it's been a while i'm shigeru
miyamoto
i have a few things i'd like to share
with you today including some news
first as you may have heard the super
mario brothers animated movie we're
developing with chris melidandry from
illumination will release next spring
and super nintendo world which is
entering its second year at universal
studios japan will also open in
hollywood california in the u.s
recently we've been working on the
finishing touches for both
today i'd like to talk a little bit
about pikmin
it's been over 20 years since the first
game and we're still working on the
series
this is pikmin bloom it's a smart device
game we started with niantic late last
year in which players all over the world
are planting flowers
here's a quick rundown of the game for
those who have yet to play it
pikmin bloom is a smart device game that
uses your location
by walking outside you can find pikmin
raise them and plant flowers together
all you need to do is take it with you
on your daily walks or outings
you can look back at the end of the day
and see where you walked
send out pikmin and collect the items
they found that day
and feed them nectar to increase their
pedals
so how many steps did we take today
while you're out and about you can also
use the ar feature to take photos with
pikmin
pikmin are all around you
let's take a quick look at my screen
i have nearly 700 pikmin
they love nectar
if you give pikmi nectar like you see
here their flowers will bloom
[Music]
you'll also see the number of steps
you've taken that day
[Music]
regarding the map the clouds will clear
along the path you walk so you can keep
a record of locations you've visited
[Music]
i normally move around within kyoto but
i've also been going to osaka to
universal studios japan
i occasionally go to tokyo as well
you'll say to yourself okay this time
i'll try walking here it makes trips and
walks a lot of fun
it's a very easy going play experience
you can enjoy just by taking it with you
i hope you'll try it out okay now to the
main event please take a look at this
hey
[Music]
that's right
pikmin 4 will launch in 2023.
we won't be showing any gameplay today
however
you'll be able to play like this
from the pikmin's perspective near the
ground
i also made a new t-shirt
nintendo switch has made controlling the
game simpler meaning you can further
concentrate on the core essence of
pikmin gameplay we call it dandori in
japanese or strategically planning
deploying and commanding the pikmin i
hope you're all looking forward to
pikmin 4. thank you
can you survive the season of death
as you cultivate a peaceful farm life in
the village of leafy
the season of death quietus continuously
returns threatening to destroy all
travel the world and find a way to put
an end to the calamity in this life
simulation rpg
along the way
allies with different motives will join
your cause
while facing numerous dangers you'll
begin to uncover the truth of this
ill-fated world
after this presentation a demo
containing the opening days of your
farm's first season will be available on
nintendo eshop
save data can be transferred to the full
game once purchased
stella launches on nintendo switch
november 4th
get ready for a devilishly good time
after 500 years umbra witch bayonetta
was revived in the present day in the
first bayonetta game she clashed with
angels to recover her lost memories
and in the second confronted demons to
save her best friend
now in this third installment she'll
fight to protect the world from the
sudden invasion of man-made bio-weapons
called homunculi
[Music]
she's gone from fighting for herself to
fighting for others
to fighting for the world
those who have overcome their past
histories with bayonetta to fight
alongside her include the journalist
luca
and another umbra witch jean
[Music]
new ally viola also joins in on the
action
a hair raising
demon summoning
globetrotting adventure awaits
in bayonetta 3
launching on nintendo switch october
28th
pre-orders are available now on nintendo
eshop
after today's nintendo direct a new
trailer delving more into gameplay will
launch on our official youtube channel
a dark fantasy mystery abounds from the
creators of danganronpa
welcome to the city of perpetual rain
many cases remain unsolved in this
corporate-controlled metropolis
[Music]
those who investigate are called master
detectives who come from all around the
world
[Music]
the spirit haunting him after they're
packed
dive into these unsolved cases as a
trainee at the detective agency
thoroughly inspect each crime scene to
gather clues and evidence
when you're ready shinigami will conjure
a realm tying the crime scene to the
truth
a mystery labyrinth
overcome obstacles and manifestations of
mysteries to edge closer to the actual
events
however mystery phantoms will attempt to
hinder your progress during each case
avoid their barrage of falsehoods and
slash through contradictions
uncover the secrets of master detective
archives raincode launching first on the
nintendo switch system spring 2023
enter the village if you dare
the latest installment in the resident
evil series is coming to nintendo switch
as a cloud version
ethan winters must face the horrors of
the village and its four fearsome lords
to rescue his abducted daughter
resident evil village cloud launches on
nintendo switch october 28th
you can download and try out the free
demo today on nintendo eshop to
pre-order the full game
the winter's expansion dlc containing a
new third-person mode
additional story content and more will
launch december 2nd
additionally
three other recent entries in the
resident evil series will be available
as cloud versions on nintendo switch
this year
it's an action-packed lineup of nintendo
switch games
vanquish foes to avenge your father in
this kung fu action brawler
by thrusting
tripping and parrying opponents you'll
break their stance and gain the upper
hand
[Music]
fall in combat and you'll get older and
weaker
in turn however you'll learn new
techniques to complete your mission
can you exact revenge before your time
runs out
sifu pummels its way onto nintendo
switch november 8th pre-orders begin
today on nintendo eshop
experience the events leading up to
final fantasy vii in this exhilarating
action rpg
zach baer is a young and ambitious
soldier operative aspiring to become a
hero
together with sephiroth and cloud he
investigates strange disappearances
within his elite unit
this remaster features enhanced hd
graphics an updated combat system and
new soundtrack arrangements
crisis core final fantasy vii reunion
launches on nintendo switch december
13th
the classic arcade shoot-em-up radiant
silver gun is coming to nintendo switch
fire different types of weapons to take
down waves of enemies
defeat multiple enemies of the same
color for a chain bonus
or take down differently colored ones
for a secret bonus
rack up these bonuses for a high score
radiant silver gun launches on nintendo
switch later today
recruit a team of shipwrecked heroes and
make your way out of a derelict space
station in this roguelike game set in
the endless universe
but it's not as easy as it sounds you'll
have to fend off continuous waves of
monsters as you make your way through
procedurally generated levels complete
various quests to unlock new heroes
weapons station areas and more
up to three players in online co-op can
attempt to escape their grim fate
do you have what it takes
endless dungeon launches on nintendo
switch next year
[Music]
the journey of world regeneration begins
anew
remaster of tales of symphonia is coming
to nintendo switch
the world of silverant is controlled by
shadowy forces called the science
to stop them a person known as the
chosen one must ascend the tower of
salvation i really hope that's true
lloyd soon embarks on a journey with
colette the current chosen one and his
childhood friend in this beloved action
rpg
they'll meet allies along the way
like the wandering aristocrat zellos
and a lumberjack who lost her emotions
after an experiment presea
other allies will also join the party
[Music]
the fate of two interconnected worlds
hangs in the balance
tales of symphonia remastered begins its
journey on nintendo switch early next
year
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
kirby's return to dreamland deluxe is
coming to nintendo switch
one day a spaceship crash lands on
planet pop star
to help magalor return to his home
planet kirby and his friends set off on
an adventure
in addition to sword
whip
and other familiar copy abilities the
new mecha copy ability makes its debut
blast foes from a distance or punch them
up close
it's packed with other powerful moves as
well the game supports local play for up
to four players on the same system
plus everyone can play as kirby while
using their favorite copy abilities
there's also a collection of sub games
to play
this includes the new sub game magalor's
tome trackers
and returning ones like samurai kirby
all sub games can be played with up to
four players
[Music]
an adventure of deluxe proportions
awaits
kirby's return to dreamland deluxe
launches on the nintendo switch system
february 24th 2023 pre-orders begin
today on nintendo eshop
as part of kirby's 30th anniversary a
remake of kirby's return to dreamland
will be released
we hope you're looking forward to this
game
thank you for watching today's nintendo
direct
this next trailer will be our last
announcement
please take a look
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you